all right man what do you got for me
buddy i just want to say uh you know
your book really helped me draw that
line between this you know because i
didn't want to mistreat women
and but i certainly didn't want to turn
into one of these beta guys but so i
tried to just befriend them right and
then uh it slowly but really chips away
at you and you end up becoming uh
a beta and uh before i knew it i i got
divorced cut cut all the ties you did
the beta sization through a thousand
concessions routine yeah
it was uh it was unfor you know uh it i
got to the point where i was just
started to go to more conferences and
started to you know go more towards my
hobby and my craft and she was trying to
compete with me just like you said in
your book
one of the red flags yeah yeah where uh
she doesn't want to see you go in the
place without her also going to the
place and it was just it was driving me
crazy um she's only going to come along
for the ride as a passenger if she sees
you as a guy that can lead her you can't
lead her as a beta i mean she's not
gonna she's not gonna yield to where
you're going and saying yes roller i
wanna i wanna support you on this
mission if she doesn't trust you a
woman's gotta trust you to lead her to
do a good job and she'll only
yield to you when she sees you as a guy
that's worthy of that trust then she'll
give it to you everybody else is
invisible to her at that point she
doesn't see other guys and generally
speaking yeah and then one of the things
that i really didn't realize uh was i
grew up in that salt lake city the
polygamist community where you know some
of these men are have very wealthy and
but i just hated the way that they
treated their wives and how did they
treat them because i mean like you
uh moth put over here define mistreating
women so why don't you give us
they um they treat them like they're the
ceo of the company and and and they
basically built a corporate structure
with no hr all the kids work for them
they take all the money all the women
do analyzation about the kids and trying
to figure out this one's good at this
this one's good at that you should put
them over here and have them doing these
different uh
things so they they treat them more like
managers
of their of their little unit
instead of the family you mean yeah but
but how is that how is that mistreating
women if you trust her to run your home
for you
because they don't care how their home
is ran they don't care about the kids
they just want to make a whole bunch of
kids and
they sort of ignore the women right
they'll just go get another wife that's
younger and uh so
you see your mom who's being promised a
farm she's been promised to horses and
all these things like they promise them
whatever it is that they want but they
call this money and then they never ever
buy them any of the things that they
said they were going to do yeah so
that's being deceptive so i understand
what you're saying
yeah it it drove me crazy and so i made
a ton of money with google ads when i
was uh in 2005 when you know and they
took it all and it didn't change any of
our situation everybody was still in
debt everything was really strange and
it was
even though we're in the same family uh
you know with all these different
brothers from other mother
some family has nikes and expensive
clothes but my family was shopping at
the thrift store and it was just super
strange um to grow up in that you know
where where you see this this
favoritization of one woman and just
complete ignoring of
did you grow up in a polygamous
household like did your dad have
multiple wives yeah and my uncles and
everybody and
how many um how many like co-wives did
he have in the family uh he he he only
had two
but uh my mom came from one of the
families that has seven or eight
brothers and sisters and they're all
polygamous and they're all part of the
bigger family so my dad swooped in and
tried to get one of the one of the more
uh and
entitled or what he called an
established family
and one thing i noticed about
a lot of these polygamists you know
communities in that part of the states
and i haven't seen all of them so i
can't draw a full con you know
conclusion but what's been presented to
me from that i've watched either on
youtube or netflix is most of these guys
they're they're basically plugged in
betas running multiple women in their
lives right like they're not unplugged
alphas if you know if i understand it
correctly like would you say that i
would say that definitely i i never
wanted to be like them so i just i
literally just left started with nothing
and figured out how to make it on my own
and now i'm to the point where
where i i just really don't now that i
got your book it was really good to help
me you know i really want to be an alpha
and get to that point but i just didn't
want to be that that guy you know and
and i've seen them as alphas because of
they run all these businesses and they
make all this money and and they do
whatever the hell they want they're
never home they own motorcycles and guns
and and
all kinds of fun stuff but they um you
know uh they're just not good people at
the end of the day right
so so there's a category in polygamy
which is which is called the alpha god
and i didn't cover it in my quadrant
because it's because it's not very
common it's very rare okay there's a
book called alpha god by dr hector
garcia if you want to get your head
around how that works properly read that
book okay
definitely
did you have a question for me tonight
or is it mostly just a share
yeah just just to share and then also
you know just to let you know that uh
you know i'm i'm i'm trying to to get
out of here uh you know before gets
too crazy i'm in florida right now but
looking at thailand um i'm thinking in
eastern uh women is florida not a good
state i mean i
think it's one of the better states
right now
it's yeah it's it's it's i just don't
really find people that i get along with
out here you know there's a lot of uh
super fakes right um happy nice to your
face and then where do you live
uh over on the brooksville area um which
is which is north of tampa
okay
so yeah i i i just don't find too many
people that i can uh
that i can actually
get to know because they'll just ghost
me right uh
you're talking about women are you
talking about men both uh i'll meet
people and and they'll seem kind of cool
but then they uh they just won't won't
interrupt well i mean you gotta
understand too that like attracts like
right so i mean if you're attracting
people that are of low caliber then
there's something missing in your life
personally you know yourself
um
i mean i don't
agree with everything jordan peterson
says but the one thing that i will
always support is you know like fix your
house first before you try to fix the
world so
if you've got problems in florida
connecting with people you're going to
have problems in thailand connecting
with people right there's still good
people all around the world
i have
i have many guys that i've connected
with over the years and a lot of them
have like come into my community they've
stayed there and they've all
not all but you know many of them have
like leveled up and become way way
better versions of themselves um and
they live all throughout north america
many of them live in canada too right
you know some of they're in the same
boat that i am like you know they've
been divorced they're an unplugged alpha
they can't leave because they've got
kids to raise you know through the
school system before they can go it's
not like they can move you know the
ex-wife and what's going on in her world
but
um
if you're finding that everybody that
you meet men and women are not meeting
standards or certain expectations
there's something wrong with you first
okay right so i mean you got to look
inside your fills you know look inside
yourself and try to figure out what that
what that is okay
all right
all right man thanks for hopping in
we'll see you later
you